[Music]
in much needed discipline news oh yeah
submitted by Sally from Arizona a former
mayor caught a burglar and spanked him
with the paddle to teach him a lesson
kept going seized and it just you're
just gonna hold it in Tucson Arizona
no because last time I did the bean
nobody said [ __ ] sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't just give it to us
he was this face you always need me you
guys broke the trust even here the
article the mayor had someone it's fake
the former me
the former mayor [ __ ] dope yeah
finger with the panel is teaching a
lesson
do you know did you know that that why
people have paddles specifically
designated for spanking really big baby
took out they barely took out spanking
like 10-15 years ago yeah you know those
battles that they have in frat houses
those are paddles these to spank people
with oh really like a spatula and this
was like 10 15 years ago Aaron got
[ __ ] yeah when he was at school he
used to get spanked by the teachers you
know what I think it is
wait I'm stronger don't move on yet let
me show her and then we are on the same
page
and those are speed holes some of them
don't have the speed holes interesting
cuz what I think especially I think
cooking special because that's about
somewhere else it's better
joe said special oh hey I have a wooden
spatula that looks like that hmm well I
like that well actually it's not a
spatula okay I use it as a spatula but
it's actually a grater the rice cooked
like the rice scooper to what do you
call it that the light died yeah yeah so
you know you know how we think that why
people don't get beat and all this stuff
you know why it's because we live in
progressive as liberal California where
the people that we know in LA and the
white people here they're more they're
like not hippie but they're different
there's a scarf people the scarf people
yes there's a positive reinforcement
people because only there's only certain
Billa wears clothes there's that beep
can't knows that's not right you can
imagine it I just saw how like softly
and slowly the scarf just moved over her
shoulder yeah yeah [ __ ] I find it
hilarious in LA when it's [ __ ] 80
degrees and I see something when your
scarf 60 or 50 degrees and it's the
scarf and [ __ ] daisy dukes and oh
yeah I was like I could see you sweat
right now take that [ __ ] scarf off
you know we buy wine whenever I travel
cuz I forget to bring it with me and
then now I just have a collection of
scarves I can never wear here ever it's
just cuz I know it looks cute but I
always see the good you could tell
there's like sweat beads like I'm gonna
commit you know [ __ ] off you look so
uncomfortable but here they used to
these to spank like up until I want to
say like the 60s no up until the 90s
Aaron got beat wait what that Aaron got
beat he's only a few years older than
that by a teacher by the teacher in
school no it's good about it like a
Christian or Catholic I thought you got
beat by his mom
no he got he got beat in elementary
school and he said in middle school
that's when that policy came in and
started weeding off and by the time he
hit high school it wasn't more like a
few months older than me
no he's a couple years older than years
wanna bet we had this conversation all
the [ __ ] time hurry you gonna yell at
a man with the neck brace I [ __ ]
broke his neck oh I got pinched I got
pinched by a teacher oh yeah my teachers
did the pinching things
she [ __ ] Duggar nail in my tricep
that [ __ ] was about to rip a muscle
tissue out so there was still negative
reinforcement like my teachers to grab
kids ears and pull them yes but but that
where that great period windows
transitioning so it's not too long ago
when but just for the record Aaron and I
are only a few months apart okay feel
better yes how much on that
how should I bet how much should I bet
$100
every Sun just give me 100 bucks 100
bucks is good 100 bucks 100 bucks okay
we're gonna text him right after watch
yep but I like favors or anything that's
more girl did this burglar break into
the mayor how I wish I could do this
Barbour name was Tony Yarber he used the
former mayor of Jackson Mississippi oh
that sounds like a [ __ ] beatdown kind
of say yeah you you disobey the law
Jackson Mississippi
yeah that his family that they were all
getting ready to go to church oh [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with Church day when his wife
noticed that there was a strange car
outside so then he thought this might be
someone that is lost
we might need directions or something
then he went over there Tony went over
to check it out when as he was walking
down the driveway he said that the door
to his truck swung open and then
instinctively he kicked it and then a
man fell out of out of the truck and so
that's when that's dope
it just went worries a prayer he thinks
Oh
a lot of the truck and then this man
who's 22 years old by the way his name
is JaJuan he want
it's Jew it's juw am o du Bois one so do
you want to want to fight would you want
to fight then he pulled it so Tony
pulled Juwan into the garage cuz they
were in the driveway and he wanted to go
somewhere that was like more enclosed
because he wasn't sure if there was
other people involved in this to badge
mayor that was a former criminal like
how does he not I think like this yeah
or maybe he just had the proper training
and he was with the government Oh major
training yeah yeah or like me the SWAT
training
yeah yeah yeah like he knew at the tide
that put the duct tape around the mouth
yeah the mayor tweeted me the [ __ ]
black bag yeah yeah mclee we've never
been a mayor so he wouldn't even we
don't know yeah I know I haven't made a
friend and I never heard about mayor
training she knows Hapkido so then when
Tony like brought him into the garage he
flipped the kid over here what the [ __ ]
yeah something he'd left him over you
saw his face and he was like oh you
think he looks like a kid that goes to
my church if a man pulled me in the
garage pulled down my pants and put me
on his lap I would say he's going to
[ __ ] me I'm just a Matt like I'm already
like scared I'm breaking into something
a man drags me in the [ __ ] garage you
flips me over I'm thinking I'm gonna get
raped cuz just blood that's that's
[ __ ] bull it's him over to the front
not the back to the garage he doesn't
see his face maybe finally like what
hope you guys are focusing on the wrong
thing let me move on
my apologies so then he tell me what the
hope biggie is because like little I'll
show you a video if you let me get to it
I know I'm just saying man is somebody
grabs me by the shirt and I can't stop
them
I'm the most scared I've ever been in my
life oh [ __ ] you're like I can't get
past his scramble you know he just still
drags me and then I don't want to flip
around but he forces me you know this is
look at my face oh [ __ ] it struck me
this guy dude what the [ __ ] it's not
mayor training
so then Tony said that the jewel hunt
said things that got him upset
so then JaJuan was saying like don't
kill me don't kill me I have a two month
old baby and that's when Tony was like
man my kids are inside right now and I
was just angry right so then his
instincts as a former school principal
kicked in and they're well he's saying
the school principal or the principal
training came in not the mayor so then
the principal training kicked in and
then he sent his daughter inside the
house to go get his paddle and then he
sits
Juwan on his lab and starts paddling on
on the back
Tony's son starts recording this whole
thing and he makes a video so then I
will show you that video now that 22 is
a [ __ ] punk down well you [ __ ] with
the wrong guy that's a messy garage no
matter how old you are when you get
spanked you still got that [ __ ] is
crazy
that was like you was sort of oh [ __ ]
that was look strong yeah he looks like
he can flip you over easily there's a
handsome man while you robbing places
bro be a model match no man was robbing
for his baby you needed to buy formula
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] tight dude that
squirm away the pain the funny thing was
they're selling I'm like wrong house
homeboy there was a bear ass right there
mayor you need to clean up your garage
I'm a messy person but even I was like
that's irresponsible maybe it was close
for a drive that he was gonna give away
that's true yeah and then
so then help them down to the police
came and then later on he found out that
the police found a gun
believed to be the the kid in the truck
or in his heart rate that he planted it
they found it they didn't say where but
they found it and that they're thinking
that when he kicked the truck door that
going was like he was separated from oh
yeah that'd have been really bad so then
that's what tony was like man I'm glad
nothing happened but that's crazy you
think like look I got my good dude I saw
this one video where this guy tried to
rob a gas station right and it was like
a husband and wife Asian team and then
basically they pulled him over the
counter and both started spanking him
real [ __ ] hard and they pulled they'd
like he had a bare ass and everything
yeah yeah it was awesome that's tight I
like stories like that I wonder if my
kid if he ever becomes if is a he you're
only gonna have girls broke oh go ahead
no cuz in my world is the kid is a boy
let that go would be bad I just want to
be able to what my kids ask so like that
25 if my kid this had been terrible
where I [ __ ] spank him 25 he's 25 I
would I would what if he took a [ __ ] on
your rose bush that's faking worthy
yesterday do something bad like rob
somebody I'm gonna try not to spank up
to 18 but after 18 if that fool [ __ ] up
i'ma beat the [ __ ] out of them and
spanking style not in the face and stuff
because I'm like these are for all the
times I shoulda spanked you and I did it
so here's [ __ ] all the times that I
owe you I'm already dedicated making
sure that my kid is physically weaker
than me that's mean it's gonna be easy
cuz he's not gonna be able do any
physical activity whatsoever you need so
taste we get into a fight I [ __ ]
spoiled eV and B make sure that they
grow up really nice so all you gotta do
is
I think beggin should happen later in
the life night in the early stages
spanking is for kids that are like you
already [ __ ] tried you yelled at him
you did all those stuff that's why
nothing affects them yeah so you got an
uppercut of them in a jaw mmm but then
like if you've always been nice and then
you [ __ ] raise your voice once it'll
make them crumble
[Music]